Scott Disick celebrates Passover with
his fam and offers a rare look at his
oldest kiddo Mason Disick the reality
star shared a few snaps to his insta
story Wednesday enjoying a Passover
seder with the three children he shares
with his ex Kourtney Kardashian that's
eight-year-old Reign sporting a yamaka a
traditional head covering worn by men in
the Jewish religion and his newly
bleached hair I mean it's a beautiful
thing and there's ten-year-old Penelope
sitting at the dinner table with her big
bro 13 year old mason Mason also wore
yamaka the same as his younger brothers
fastened to his head with a cliff Mason
rarely appears on his famous family's
Hulu series and he's hardly ever on
their social media the last time Scott
shared a snap of his son was back in
June 2022 posting this pick of Mason
alongside the caption dream big my
little man before that it was this pick
of Mason with rain on the couch in
October 2021 for boys night
when I see my little boy I'm overwhelmed
with joy it's honestly like a little
piece of me was just reborn as for court
she shared this throwback moment with
her
with her on their shared birthday last
year writing December 14 one of the best
days of my life twice and forever once I
had my son I was a completely different
person just knowing that you have that
responsibility to take care of this
little precious angel like that just
kicks in back in January 2020 Mason made
his Tick Tock debut with the help of his
mom and YouTube Star David dobrik famous
relative check
Mason's account has since been deleted
and he's managed to stay out of the
spotlight but back in December A source
told E.T Scott and Court's son
celebrated his bar mitzvah with a party
at a nightclub in West Hollywood a
lavish celebration for the bar mitzvah
boy who's half Jewish on his father's
side being in Temple feels great it
really does
ET Source said at the time that Scott
took the lead on planning and he was so
happy with how it turned out he was
really proud of Mason and glad to be
celebrating this Milestone with him at
the end of the day I mean you just want
to be happy as for the guest list
Mason's siblings Penelope and Rain were
there along with his cousin Northwest
ants Kim and Khloe Kardashian and Kylie
Jenner and his grandma Kris Jenner I'm
so lucky I get to see my grandchildren
very often like every day so it's the
best as for Mason's parents court and
Scott who ended their relationship in
2015 after dating on and off for 10
years our source says the two were very
friendly with each other talking and
hanging out at the party I mean I think
you just gotta figure out really what's
important to you and while we didn't get
to see a whole lot of the bash on social
media hopefully we'll get to see Mason's
big day and that Passover seder when
season three of the family's Hulu series
returns May 25th I wish wish I could
tell you this is going to be a mild
relaxing Serene season
it's not
[Music]